foreign
s fewer GPS
new Sky analysis paints a grim picture
especially in the most deprived and most
diverse areas how much extra pressure a
GDP is facing it is just constant that's
all you just can't switch off you're
always thinking about that patient that
you could have done more for you're
always thinking about other patients
that you need to deal with there is a
constant pressure to do things 274
patients have phoned us already today
that may be 700 on a Monday and there
just aren't 274 slots that we can find
for those patients to get what they need
today
analysis of the latest figures by the
Sky News data and forensics team shows
what GPS are up against this is the
number of practices in England and well
steady growth from the mid 80s onwards
but then nearly one in five have shot
over the last decade and on top of that
there are fewer GPS here in Black
they're dealing with a lot more patience
in yellow even since 2016. the problem
gets worse depending where you are
specifically how wealthy the area you
live in is the most deprived areas here
on the left have the fewest GPS per
patient and even within those deprived
areas GP serving people from Minority
backgrounds are the most stretched South
Asian communities have nearly a thousand
more patients per GP than white
communities and GPS from across the
country have been in touch to talk about
the pressure and we already have
collapsed in all fairness and if
trying to tell you that we haven't
collapsed they're absolutely wrong we're
a bucket full of holes so you are
putting in lots of trainees they're
taking on the training post but they're
leaving this has been coming for about
10 years I've been a GP 30 years I think
the last 10 years this has been an
increasing problem
um and it's just not been addressed
properly
the Department of Health and Social care
told us that they were investing in
primary care and that there were 500
more doctors working in general practice
compared to a year ago for the GPS we
spoke to that is not nearly enough to
plug the holes that already exist Tom
Cheshire Sky News